when i fought with floyd i was 23  23. how much have you grown from 23 now  so much i i always seven years right  yeah i always think i i need to fight  first with coro  lara and all of that guys and then  floyd that's what it is yeah no  that's that's what it is uh i'm okay so  you think at 23 you think you're  it was still it was kind of premature i  need i need more experience  more mature yeah i think that helps them  more than anything  fights like that helps you want to  handle you  let me say well i can go 12 rounds with  the best fighter in the world  yeah it makes you better yeah i i agree  with that i don't i don't take that  fight  like i lose i take that fight like  i i'm learned from that fight if because  of that loss  this is where he's at now yeah that's  why we think about that  that loss puts him here  you